faced with a crisis of unprecedented
proportions over the escalation of knife
violence in the country at a crime
summit this week the government unveiled
a new possible secret weapon what might
it have been tougher legislation extra
police officers on the streets longer
sentences no none of the above
it was teachers yes those charged with
the unenviable task of trying to impart
knowledge to our young frequently
against their pupils will and now on the
front line in the fight against knife
crime as they could be instructed to
inform on any youngster they think might
be involved in or about to get involved
in street crime or belong to a gang a
most worrying of all they could face
legal action if they don't inform what
don't this government again teachers are
already as stretched enough acting as a
cross between social workers cops and
bouncers they've precious little time
left to actually teach of course if a
youngster is clearly descending to a
life of violent crime they need to act
but what makes the government think they
don't already you know we've debated
this problem of knife crime and the
tragedy of young people dying on the
streets a number of times I feel like
there is a growing air of Surrey
allottee about this debate because there
are many teachers who notice when a
child is going off the rails and would
really like to be able to help that
young person already many teachers feel
that as part of their pastoral care that
is something they should do this is the
climate where in Lewisham which is AB
London borough that's been affected by
no crime some schools have lost three
hundred pounds per pupil per year
because of cars schools in other parts
of the country in Stockport having to
close at lunchtime because they don't
have the resources to run all day the
idea that in this climate where schools
have been absolutely hammered by
austerity they are now in a position to
take a more proactive stance in
monitoring the well-being of young
people is ridiculous but I think on the
where I disagree with you is that I
think you are partly in agree it is part
of what teachers do and I just wanna say
you know I used to work as a criminal
defense barrister I have defended young
people who've been involved in stabbings
one of the most profound frustrations is
that in so many cases you will have
parents who say my child has
psychological problems he needs a mental
health intervention
support he needs pastoral care I've
asked my MP I've asked my local
authority I've asked my child and
adolescent mental health services I've
asked the teachers
nobody has helped me we wait until a
young person is in court where the state
is spending sometimes hundreds of
thousands of pounds on trying and
punishing that young person to unlock
resources that could have helped them in
a preventative way earlier down the line
the whole system is completely broken
but respectfully if you come to my
central point which is it is it a
teacher's job and if the teacher fails
they then get him foot they don't just
in a sentence just come back to that
I'll come to you then Phil I'm realistic
with our current resources but I don't
think it's I think it's inevitable and
it's inevitable when you look at
everything teachers are having to do
they are taking on more of a role of
social workers would I have designed
that no but teachers will tell you
that's been the situation for years now
I agree of unique but it shouldn't form
teachers to be to be policing this
however by default it does because if I
take my little Johnny to school and I'll
kiss him on the cheek and I say and you
go son have a good day and I walk away
I've left my kid in the custody of that
school
therefore it's there that that schools
responsibility now to look after the
well-being of my kid
if those teachers can't identify when
things are going wrong and somebody
pulled something that does my client
feels the dad what so I can't walk into
school it's not a teacher to identify
that your son's a tearaway why aren't
you identifying if you're the ID may
well do but his his problems may stem
inside school he doesn't display that at
home because he's on his own when he
goes to school he's got his peers he
shows off and he said he's like that
that's when he becomes a problem because
he's got other people around always to
always say to my mom you say you're a
show-off Phil I said what a show-off you
only show off from this other piece of
waste the issue is this is again
Authority up there saying to a bunch of
teachers here you got to now do this
it's complete waste of time
it will be far better to have involved
the education system said look you tell
us what we can do about this you can see
where you can help can you make because
clearly there's a whole range of factors
but when you're closing down also use
centers although everything these kids
could go to because of austerity as you
say and then side know you we're gonna
insist that you teachers and you're
being trouble if you don't do it I've
got to be part of this system of
reporting I mean I agree with you yeah
they'll do it anyway but they're not
good but the idea that you're suddenly
it's it's a disciplinary offence of me
because when I carry when I read most
worryingly of all there's the deposit I
heard you I think always not in
agreement with that because a teacher
could lose his or her job of course
and I'm sure teachers already report
kids they think are going off the rails
am i carrying knives I'm sure they do
but you know and I I haven't I'm not
always supportive of teachers because
that you know I know when they talk
about the overwork and I think they are
14 weeks old to get over that however on
this I'm 100% with you because they are
not they are not policemen we have a
hundred and twenty two thousand
policemen in this country it's if we are
always we know and we do know this that
kids are walking through the school
gates with knives in their pockets why
isn't there a copper outside the gates
or two coppers that taking the knives
every day for two three weeks how else
are we gonna crack this how else are we
gonna get school but my but okay but
it's not a teacher's job and the thing
is teachers if they confront some more
than I then they're not wearing stab
vest they're not wearing body cams
they're not protected and they're not
paid to be policemen let the policemen
who were paid to control crime do we
fight out of touch with what's going on
in schools I'll never forget I went and
I was mentoring the school in West
London I went and there was a whole
classroom where they had sinks for
washing up an ironing boards and I said
to the head also you're teaching the
children how to wash off an iron so no
no this is for the parents we get the
parents in and teach them how to do
domestic skills that they don't know how
to do schools have been doing this I'm
not saying it's ideal it's the reality
that teachers will tell you they have no
choice I just want to show you what
somebody who's been very deeply affected
by this issue kion Prince's father Mark
Prince says about what children need
from school if they're to tackle these
problems you have no purpose in life
they don't know who they are they need
to be inspired they need the right kind
of society that's giving out this
message they need to when they go into
school that they're being inspired at
school and I don't think that the school
system has this thing set up it would be
great if every child at home got the
inspiration the sense of purpose the
values and the resilience they need but
the reality is they don't and so we have
these children captive they are in our
schools we pay for them through our
taxes we have teachers who want to help
them but we're not creating an
environment where they can take it again
kids they wouldn't the kids but that guy
is completely right kids need role
models they need somewhere to draw their
inspiration they need people they can
relate to they need people I talked to
the corporal's that trained me and it's
the first man I've ever came across they
need people they can relate to and
moreover people that can point them in
the right direction
it's seriously I'm massive about it I
look at the cadet forces now sorry can I
look at the cadet forces now and the
people that work with us cadet force is
there great inspiring people that
getting youngsters I don't care if they
don't wonder them for the army but it
helps them to move on in a progressive
way when I saw Theresa May making this
speech sister let's let's just see what
she actually said because this is the
biggest hypocrisy of your look at this
you
this is the woman who five years ago
reduce the powers of stop and search by
80% because she said it was offensive to
black people it is black people who have
been slaughtered by other black people
now kids are being assassinated in the
street often on the orders of adult and
dealers and and there we have her who
actually stopped or searching people for
knives and weapons saying that you know
clumsily done though but we aren't
getting a long way from your subject
actually you need a comprehensive
approach to to all sorts of problems
when everyone's got the answer to this
they don't know but what it isn't is to
just say to teachers now it's your
problem and already that getting
blenders I forgot it was but one of it
one of the teaching you bosses said the
other day the government was hinting the
other day that excluding violent pupils
from schools was one of the reasons that
knife crime was rocketed so they're
being blamed already and if that's not
they're probably they exclude kids
because the dangerous world of pupils